for me one of the meaning in life is to
see how I can actually imagine a better
future for the people that we design for
design is an act of optimism to
understand the world around us
maximizing opportunities and offering
appropriate Solutions
my name is Wong mansang I'm one of the
co-founders of waha I am hongway I'm a
director here at wuha Architects we are
the designers for the Singapore Pavilion
Expo 2020 Dubai
the Singapore Pavilion for us is a
self-sufficient nature positive topic
it offers the opportunity for Singapore
to share with the world how we tackle
issues like climate change through
design through Innovations through
planning
we really want to create that sense of
lush verden tropical Singapore in Dubai
we find this challenge very exciting
we use today's technology to achieve for
us something very important as a target
a self-sufficient and nature positive
Pavilion
we had a full roof of PV panels that
generates the clean energy to power the
entire Pavilion including desalination
of groundwater that is being used in The
Pavilion
and this nature positive environment for
us is where we see the future
we know why we need to care about
climate change
the how it's the challenge to further
push the boundary in design in making
buildings and making environment not
just better for the climate but for the
life within
I think the messages that we embed in
our designs will show the way for future
and how we as human beings can coexist
with nature